this movie is called paranoia and no one
in the movies ever really paranoid a
couple times liam hemsworth is convinced
someone's following him but he's right
so it's not paranoia if you're right
just you know those mists titled movies
this is this is really one of them
[Music]
generic conveniences the movie or for
the sake of being PC and accurate
paranoid so paranoia stars liam
hemsworth that's Chris Hemsworth's
brother he plays this entry-level tech
guy in this company run by Gary Oldman
then he gets canned and Gary Oldman's
like ok now that you're fired I'm gonna
hire you to infiltrate Harrison Ford's
company in which case you're gonna steal
tech from him and show me what he's
doing so I could steal it could be
interesting right it's not though this
movie really is a mess and everything
this movie is so convenient and nothing
suspenseful at all even how Liam
Hemsworth is recruited his [ __ ] he
gets fired from Gary Oldman's company
they still have the company card so he's
like alright everyone let's go spend 16
grand in this club and just live it up
for the night have a good time and he
meets the hot chick in this movie and
they bang that night she's classy she's
a lady like that Gary Oldman's like
technically speaking you stole from me
so I'm gonna report you you're gonna go
to prison or you're gonna help me
infiltrate Han Solo's company and steal
his deck which is fine but then he has
this whole speech form race like you
work for me for a purpose you want to
aspire to be better than your father and
it's true after that he's like you know
why you went to that club that night
because you want to know how our side
lives you can be part of our side is
that a positive though I'm pretty sure
if I were Gary Oldman I'd be like all
right you go into that club and spending
all that money after being fired shows
me that when the chips are down you're
gonna give in to your basic human
instincts and urges I just don't want
someone that unstable and that emotional
to be the one who infiltrates this
company the fact that he even saw it is
a positive reminding me of Ted when
Ted's alive because you got your wife's
box you're my breath and the manager
who's interviewing him for the jobs like
talking to me like that takes guts
we need guts you're hired it's just
absurd as ridiculous I'm like it's not
it's dumb that's not the only
convenience this movie has so many
conveniences in which case they just
write their way out of it example he's
gonna have to steal tech techs gonna be
in a vault what's in a vault the pass
codes and thumb prints and [ __ ] like
that that you can't get past but
Hemsworth has to get past it like the
writer of this movies like how would he
get past it well if only they used an
app for thumb prints resident an actual
thumbprint that would be easy okay we're
going to have people in this movie use
an app for thumbprint so he can hack it
and use it convenient and done if you're
gonna make a generic espionage movie at
least don't be that lazy the romance in
this movie I didn't buy I'll tell you
what romance I did buy more than the
actual romance between Liam Hemsworth
Worthen that one chick he banged in the
bar who's now playing hard-to-get after
he nailed her the first night he met her
it's like too late dude bar chick they
were just being a [ __ ] tease if you play
hard-to-get after he's already gotten
you in any case the dude who played
havoc from x-men first class starts
dating this nerdy chick he's worked with
Niall got fired together so they all
bonded for some stupid reason I was more
invested in their relationship that you
see like twice in the movie the actual
romance relationship that's supposed to
be in the forefront of the movie Carrie
Oldman in Harrison Ford they try their
best in this movie there's this one
scene where they're sitting down and
they're you know doing their evil CEO
speak they're like gonna steal your tech
yeah well I'm gonna buy all your shares
and bury you under the company you can
tell what they really want to say
Harrison Ford wants to be like ran this
movie because Star Wars Episode seven
doesn't come out for a couple more years
Episode seven is too far away apparently
that's part of the movie by far is when
Victor Von Doom from the shitty
fantastic four movies is going to kill
Liam Hemsworth Hemsworth Dex amande then
runs away like if I were happens worth
that would be my main concern right
there not the fact that I'm probably
gonna die not the fact that these really
powerful people are gonna snuff me
behind a dumpster or something but the
fact that the security cameras certainly
picked me up running like that and
that's going to go viral on YouTube
titled dude runs away like a fairy
princess after almost getting killed I'd
watch that video I would favor and like
and comment on that video it's kind of
like hey Vaughn doom if you want to
catch him leave the tooth that you just
lost from him decking you under your
pillow
he'll come that night the movie has no
suspense whatsoever the scene where he's
breaking into the vault spoiler alert do
you really care it's like alright two
out of three failed attempts the next
failed attempt you know the alarms are
gonna sound I had no doubt in my mind
like well the third time is gonna work
how it's gonna go and it did I was right
and thus there was still no suspense in
the movie I was gonna say you're not
gonna remember it in t-minus a couple
hours but if you can see a time-lapse of
my drive home from the theater to my
house it'd just be like there's nothing
worse than a bad espionage movie and
generic conveniences is [ __ ] or it's
the worst espionage movie out there not
bad we're going worst what is the one
that you hate most whatever it is
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more just don't watch this
[Music]
another spoiler alert but this is just
what I think of at the end of this movie
all the companies follow Liam Hemsworth
starts his own company in the chick
who's now hates him the main chick comes
to him and he's like well I'll give you
share options if you work for me and
she's like you got to do better than
that I just want him to be like okay how
about the fact that no one will hire you
because your name is tarnished because
you were a higher-up and a producer and
a company that got seized by the FBI so
you really have no option so how 750 an
hour no shares you still want to be cute
negotiate no okay that's what I thought
don't be an [ __ ]
today that's just managed it would at
least show that he learned something
from the experience